[Music]
my name is Ashe Ahluwalia I am a product
manager for the Google cloud platform
and I work on transfer products products
that help customers get data from
wherever it is into the Google cloud and
we primarily have for this session three
big goals one is to help you understand
how do I get started on a big transfer
project 2 what options does Google have
available and how do they work and then
3 what are some best practices that I
can employ so that I can have a
successful transfer initiative so those
are three things we hope to cover here
so to start with I want to talk a little
bit about the mission of our transfer
product suite it aligns really well with
Google's mission to organize the world's
information and make it universally
accessible and useful
from the transfer perspective what that
means is we want to make sure that your
data is delivered where and when you
need it so that you can make it useful
for your workloads and for your business
now there are a lot of different
applications of your data in Google
cloud you could be running an analytical
workflow you might be archiving data as
part of your hybrid or multi cloud
strategy or maybe you're retiring some
legacy infrastructure and which case you
need to move the data off of it before
you do that retiring and to be able to
do all of these amazing things you need
often as a first step to move your data
and what I often find at least in my
conversations with customers is that
it's easy to look at this and say oh
that's easy that's the easiest parts you
know we'll deal with that later but
often it's much harder than it looks
sometimes you have so much data
petabytes and petabytes of data the
first problem is figuring out what data
you have and which of that which subset
of that data am I actually going to
transfer and then maybe let's say you
figured out what day do you want to move
but you don't have enough bandwidth to
move it or maybe you've done both of
these things but now getting access to
data is the problem it's behind a
firewall you need to get internal
approve
these are all challenges that you have
to face when you're moving your data and
then finally sometimes you just may not
have the or gree sources there's nobody
available to actually say move the data
now what we aim to do with our transfer
product suite is to provide you a set of
solutions that are simple reliable and
secure and hopefully remove or at least
minimize some of these barriers to
transferring your data now most
successful transfer projects don't start
from moving your first byte
in fact they start well before that in
constructing a good transfer plan and
with that I'd like to invite my
colleague Scott up to the stage from
unity3d
Scott's team recently conducted a very
large transfer project and he's here to
tell you a little bit about how you can
make a great plan and ensure success
from your transfer project hello
everyone my name is Scott and I work for
unis technologies I'm a DevOps engineer
on the cloud team and we recently
utilized storage transfer service to
move a large amount of files from s3 to
GCS so what do we do unity is a creator
of the world's most widely used
real-time 3d development platform and
what were we transferring 500 plus
terabytes of many files varying in size
from s3 to GCSE uni was the process of
migrating mini service structure
infrastructure components to GC P so we
had several challenges and requirements
and one of our first requirements was no
downtime for our customers another
requirement was ensuring that all of our
files made it to the in bucket we had
some piles actually mini files that had
an older legacy naming pattern so we had
to take extra precaution to make sure
all of them arrived so some of the some
of the requirements are actually the
challenges we had were updating our
service code prior to handle this no
downtime scenario we also couldn't use
the web console for this because of the
complexity and the number of file
so we utilized the STS API directly
which helped us keep track of the actual
transfers as they were as they were
happening so how did we organize as a
team first of all another team in unity
had already done a transfer project
theirs was slightly less complicated
because they had naming conventions that
were consistent so we essentially took
some of the code that they had some
rapper scripts and tailored and tailored
them to our needs
so our devs did a service code prep to
deal with where to read and where to
write files during this process and so
DevOps prepared scripts to test these
transfers from from our dev and stage
environments before the final production
run so once the developers employed the
code we just we did the storage
transfers from Devon stage and we did
things like transfer speed times logging
any errors recorded and test runs to
pave way for final production use so
some of the tactics we use it led up to
this transfer event speed tests were
performed for transferring the files we
did in both regional and multi-regional
buckets the in bucket was multi-regional
for us so we also tested a few transfers
with smaller data and buckets that were
in the same regions or close to the s3
and GCSE regions the final process was
from regional actually we transferred
from regional to regional and then
inside of GCS we did multi-regional
transfer so some of our key takeaways
and best practices these transfers can
be complicated so devs and DevOps work
together to break down the process
also I suggest if your team can find any
internal experts that have done this
transfer before because you can learn
from what they've they've gone through
and maybe adapt your transfer to their
from there their transfer so how to prep
for the transfer do lots of testing so
testing will help you understand what to
do in case you have problems in the
production run it also gives you a good
benchmark for performance it also may
predict impact your production code so
know what your workload is also consider
the
cost to transfer we transferred over
public internet from s3 so you know you
have egress costs some best practices
evaluate all your transfer options also
consider temporary regional buckets for
your sink before you go multi-regional
so if you have to sink again you can
have time to sink to your single
regional bucket and then decide you know
what to do from there have a really good
plan another final suggestion is have
service accounts ready with STS rolls
you're limited to a certain number of
jobs per day so if you run out of jobs
you can always use one of your other
service accounts that are ready for the
process and most of all prepare for any
issues or mistakes thank you thank you
so much Scott for sharing some of your
experiences from your transfer project
so one of the questions that will come
up is part of your transfer planning or
a very common question that comes up is
how long is my transfer gonna take now
there's a big component of that which is
you know what Scott just talked about
all of the process organizational work
testing and prep leading up to the
transfer event that's a big portion of
the time for a transfer project to
complete but once you've gone beyond
that if you're talking just about I have
some data here I have some bytes and I
need to move them over there you know
typically there are two big factors that
drive transfer times you know the first
is how much data are you gonna move and
what bandwidth do you have to move it so
just to get a sense from people in the
room and I'll try my best to see your
hands with this light how many people in
this room have a connection to the
public internet or to Google cloud
directly that's more than a hundred
megabits per second okay a few hands are
up how many of you have a connection
that is faster than one gigabits per
second okay just one or two people okay
one last question how many of you have
no idea how fast your connection is to
GCP or the public Internet okay a lot of
you so for those of you that are in that
bucket
you already know one of the questions
that you need to start asking now based
on the answers to these questions you
can get a pretty wide spectrum of
outcomes your transfers can take
anywhere from minutes or hours to many
days or even weeks so it's important to
understand this upfront and it helps you
clarify what options you should consider
now another way to think about this is
to think about how close quote unquote
or far your data is based on your
bandwidth so on the very left hand side
of this spectrum here is data that you
could consider close to you so say for
instance you're moving data within
Google Cloud you know between two Google
cloud data centers that's gonna go over
a very high bandwidth pipe that Google
has provisioned and so even if you're
moving a large amount of data it's gonna
show up pretty fast in that sense that
data is pretty close to you whenever you
need it you can get it whereas on the
other end of the spectrum let's say you
have a data center outpost on a
mountaintop it has a satellite link you
know that's really slow or maybe it has
no connection to the internet at all in
which case even a small amount of data
will take a long time to get to you and
so that is kind of a way to think about
data that's far away so this is the
spectrum on which we're thinking about
talking talking-- through the options
that are available for moving data in
Google today
so we'll start with the leftmost just
data that's close to you with the cloud
storage transfer service now this
product is specifically optimized to
move data from other clouds into GCP for
instance if you're moving data from s3
into GCS and it's used for a lot of
different purposes
customers sometimes use it for archival
and backup it's part of their multi
cloud strategy sometimes they'll use it
as part of an analytical workload
they'll load data from s3 into GCS and
then put it into bigquery or run some of
our machine learning products against it
or they might be just moving data within
GCS you know moving with
Twain GCS bucket in one region to
another now today this product supports
pulling data from s3 GCS and any web
addressable HTTP data source it can move
data you know just one time or you can
set it up to run transfers every day
every day at 6 o'clock move my data over
please and it supported wherever GCS
works today so what I'll go through now
is just a quick walkthrough of how this
product works it's a pretty simple
product first to find it you go into
cloud console our web GUI and you go
into storage and underneath there will
be an option called transfer if you
click on that you'll have the option to
create a transfer pretty pretty
straightforward and when you create a
transfer we're gonna ask you for three
things what data do you want to move
where do you want to move it and when do
you want to move it that's it so the
first thing what data do you want to
move so this in this example we're
moving data from an s3 bucket so we'll
ask you for your bucket name your access
credentials so we can read the data and
then we also have some optional filters
you can give us so if for instance you
wanted to move only the files or
modified last week we can filter that
and only move that data for you the
second step is to tell us where do you
want to move this data which is very
similar to the first step just tell us
what GCS bucket you want to move the
data into as simple as that and then
finally you tell us when you want to
move the data you can start moving the
data right now once you hit done or you
can schedule it to run nightly as I
mentioned before if you want to have
this be a continuous process so it's
just that simple and once you kick this
off there is a reporting GUI that'll
help you track you know ok where all
your transfers how much data has been
moved how much data needs is left if
there are any errors you can go look up
the errors and resolve them and it's
just that simple
no provisioning to do no other setup
just give us your credentials tell us
these three things and you're ready to
go now the next step on the spectrum is
if let's say your data is a little bit
away so perhaps it's a networking link
that's provisioned by your Colo or you
provision yourself at your corporate
office data center so it might be a
little bit slower for that we have a
product called gsutil GS util is
designed to move data from your data
center that you operate in to Google
Cloud it's a command line utility which
means you can use it in an ad hoc basis
and your day-to-day workflow is just
invoke it from the shell or you can put
it in a script as part of a cron job it
works like any other command-line
utility you can also run it in a
continuous mode so you can run it in the
background it'll sit and listen on a
directory and whenever new data comes in
or data is updated it'll push that data
to a GCS bucket now in addition to these
two modes a continuous sync and copy it
also supports streaming so if you have a
UNIX command you're running you can pipe
it to GS util and it'll stream the
output to a GCS object underneath the
covers that also supports automatic
retries encryption and GCS object
versioning now gsutil has a lot of
options I'm gonna go through a few that
I found in my experience customers find
to be pretty useful so let's just walk
through those now so the first is how do
I get this to go fast one option I
always recommend is to use the - M flag
for GS util what this triggers is that
it runs the GS util process in a
multi-threaded mode so that many many
threads inside the GS util process are
pushing many files in parallel to the
cloud you almost always want to use this
now let's say that's not enough let's
say you have you know running GS util
and it's using up three gigabits per
second of your bandwidth it's pretty
good but you have a ten gigabits per
second link so how do I use up my
bandwidth so what we recommend there is
to run GS util across multiple hosts or
multiple processes what you would do is
partition your data upfront and then you
kick off multiple GS you tell command
line invitations to run the data
transfer in parallel so for instance I
run gsutil on directory one subdirectory
one then I run gcutil on subdirectory
two and then I run gsutil on
subdirectory three on machine number two
and all those GSU tails will run in
parallel and that way you can fill up
your pipe now let's say you do this
you're still gonna have one other
problem what if I have a really big file
a hundred gigabyte file well it's gonna
get mapped to one thread and one of
these gsutil processes and I got to just
sit there and wait for that threat to
finish that's gonna take forever
so for that scenario we have a feature
called parallel composite uploads what
we'll do is for large files it'll break
those files up into chunks and transfer
the chunks in parallel so you don't get
bottlenecked on large files in your
transfer now I'll just go through a few
other assorted tips and tricks with this
tool the first is controlling bandwidth
so in some situations some customers
will say I want to be able to limit how
much bandwidth gsutil uses so that I can
preserve some of my bandwidth for my
existing loads in my existing workloads
in my datacenter and unfortunately
gsutil has no native support but you can
use command line utilities like trickle
to control how much bandwidth gcutil is
using a second common task is when your
especially if you doing archival is I
want to save my file metadata how do I
do that so you can use the - B option on
GS util which will preserve all of your
POSIX metadata into GCS object metadata
so it'll preserve that for you and then
finally for people that are worried
about accidental overwrites you can use
the - an option and that'll that'll
ensure that if a GCS object already
exists GS util will not overwrite it so
if that's a concern someone fat-fingers
something or you just want to make sure
you never lose data that's something you
should look into now as I said before GC
util has a lot of options this is just a
very small subset of them if you're
curious to learn more I suggest you go
and look at our online web documentation
on GS util which is a pretty
comprehensive listing of all the things
that GS util can do and with that let me
hand it off to my colleague Ben we'll
talk about some other transfer
options thanks ash all right so that's
me
I'm the product manager on the Google
transfer team all right so we have
talked about cloud transfer service for
cloud to cloud transfers we have talked
about gsutil found prem to cloud
transfers we have a reasonable network
connectivity
what about locations where you don't
have network connectivity or not enough
we have a lot of customers who do
e-commerce who serve content from their
data centers so you think that a lot of
them will have you know enough bandwidth
to upload like terabytes of the other to
cloud the reality is that they use all
that bandwidth for production use right
to serve content to run ecommerce you
don't know suck up all that bandwidth to
upload a few hundred terabytes of the
other cloud and bring them on your whole
system and your business as well and the
other option is well why can't we just
provision more bandwidth it's not as
easy as that right because of cost of
time you have to sign maybe a two-year
agreement with your ISP and if you are
just doing a one-time transfer it's
probably not worth it so this way we
talk about the offline transfer use case
for situations where you have very
little network bandwidth or you have no
bandwidth at all for example you have a
data center up in a mountain somewhere
and Google's product is called transfer
appliance so the picture of the
appliance that you see here is a 2-u
storage server it can be racked in your
data center it has a usable capacity of
about 80 terabytes and this is is very
inexpensive we ship it to you over night
yeah you rack it load data to it ship it
back to us and we'll upload that data
for you before I go into use cases the
picture here is of our bigger appliances
of our bigger appliance it's a 4u form
factor
usable capacity about 400 terabytes
this is a pretty big box
so most of our customers will have this
sitting on their data center floor so
let's talk about use cases number one
use case here which we encountered very
often is where customers really like the
idea of running their workloads in cloud
machine learning data analytics and so
on and so forth but then they run into a
chicken-and-egg problem right you have
all that data you cannot convince your
CIO CEO to fun like larger network types
so how do you get all that data to cloud
to prove that you know cloud has value
for your company so we have customers
who order an appliance just a small one
tier one hundred shippers 17 terabytes
of data run ml run some data analytics
say hey you know it works right there's
great value for the business and that's
where they get agreement from management
to invest in more network bandwidth and
so on and so forth other use cases
including seeding backups of cloud and
we'll talk about that in a bit data
center migration large archival moves so
where you are shopping now on the error
center you may want to move all the data
to cloud before you actually shut it
down and and you know obviously your old
service all right so how do you get one
the transfer appliance service is now
available in the US and Canada it's also
available in the EU you basically order
the appliance online on cloud console
under the storage section and you
basically fill up this thing this is you
know how you fill it up there's a
content you know that's kind of optional
but how we work this service is that
it's not automated at the back right so
what I like to say is that there's a
human being behind the service so they
that's a nice thing because ash was
saying earlier moving a lot of data is
not easy but it is not something that we
want we don't do ship you the appliance
and you know like go figure it out
so we would like to work with our
customers hand in hand to make sure that
your data moves are successful
again the onboarding process is very
easy right you request an appliance we
ship it to you you fill it up ship it
back to us we'll upload the data for you
and then you figure out where you want
to put it in cloud OneNote how many
Canadians are here in the room no I
don't see anybody one okay so how this
works for Canada is that the data are
blue will be based in the US we haven't
set up a center in Canada yet so we
should be the appliance you should get
back to us in the u.s. we'll upload the
data I mean in case you're worried about
security the next two slides for now we
talked about that okay so set up a
configuration is pretty straightforward
this is a standard server like those of
you who are familiar with IT hardware
the picture that you see here is the
back of the big server standard power
connectors standard copper Ethernet
connectors and we also support fiber
optic we do provide the SFP+
transceivers there are some bandwidth in
tech in compatibilities across different
standards so we'll work with you to
figure out whether what we provide is a
sufficient for your network and we also
support network aggregation right so you
see here therefore network ports so we
can run as fast as 40 kicks per second
so network is not a bottleneck and
talking about bottlenecks a lot of times
when we work with customers we have lots
of very small files they they kind of
complained that you know copying files
from the existing file servers Isilon
that apps are too slow it is mainly
because of the you know billions of
small files that they're trying to pull
out this is something that customers
will have to deal with right kind of
like reading data from the files
obviously once the data has been read up
on original file systems everything else
is pretty quick okay so stop talking
about security the key point here is
data is always encrypted at rest in
transit we Google don't need the keys to
upload your data so customers keep and
control your keys the data is encrypted
when is copy
onto the appliance and customers will
decrypt the data in their own GCP
project once the data has been uploaded
and then what happens to the appliance
after you ship it back to us and after
the data has been uploaded we do a
secure wipe of all the drives we
reinstall the OS and applications for
the next customer so it's like getting a
new appliance so quick security summary
so you own right you the customer owns
the encryption keys you manage that data
is always encryption in transit we
upload the encrypted data into what we
call a staging bucket and then you
decrypt that within your own GCP project
and then we wipe the appliances wipe
certificates are available obviously for
all of customers they find it's very
important right for audit purposes with
that I'd like to hand you off to keep
our cool talk about one of the use cases
for transfer plains hi my name is Deepak
Verma director of product management at
convo and we're one of the vendors that
support transfer appliance on Prem so
I'll start at 10,000 foot level this is
kind of a blueprint blueprint
architecture what we can perform with
Google Cloud so break down the
architecture on the left side we've got
a lot of customers that are running
various type of workloads that could be
VM workloads databases applications not
just flat files that may need to get
transferred you got CommVault components
who call it the VSA that's capable of
transferring or writing that data into a
GCS bucket directly transfer appliance
is something that we supported recently
as a mechanism to transfer large amounts
of data and I'll get into kind of one
versus the other one once you're in GC
GCP you've got a number of options that
you can can use first off we could you
can obviously protect GCU workloads
virtual machines and applications within
those workloads just as they were you
would on an on-prem environment and
right to GCS bucket other other
components of GCP that we
or to our file store so you can back
that up as though it were an on-prem nas
and write that again that data to GCSE
within GCSE you support tearing just
like you would an on-prem you would
write to a standard tier data and then
maybe after a period of time you want to
move that to cheaper storage to deeper
archive you can move that to a cold line
so you've got flexibility to do that and
one of the things that I put on there is
actually protection to from so not only
can you read the data from GCSE but you
can also write to GCSE in other words
GCSE protection so I want to double
click on the transfer appliance
component and talk through use cases
that customers have brought up to us so
the first one is migration of of
existing data so what this means is
there may be hundreds of terabytes or
petabytes of data that may be sitting on
Prem typically where we've seen it is
elimination of those long term silos
some industries have seventy a retention
others have up to now up to thirty year
retention that they must maintain data
and today it's sitting in tape libraries
it could be sitting in virtual tape
libraries it could sitting in dee doop
appliances and they want to move that to
the cloud so going back to ashes comment
earlier it just doesn't make sense to
put hundreds of Giga bits of network
connectivity to get that transfer done
so this is where appliance comes in
comes in handy so use case there ends up
becoming what we call an auxiliary copy
which is basically making a copy of that
data putting it onto a transfer
appliance and then bringing it up into
GCS the second use case is seeding so
maybe it's a net new project where they
want to forego old data so we're gonna
start backing up to GCS however for the
amount of data that we have there's no
option to perform a full so I'll get to
an example here pretty shortly but the
full would take a considerable amount of
time and you want to size your bandwidth
for that full capacity because you're
not going to be doing full backups on a
daily basis so the call is kind of a
full or a baseline backup the third use
case is pretty interesting it's popped
up more and more is air gapped and this
is more for ransomware protection where
you truly want to copy the of data that
is not tied into your production network
so there are cases where customers have
actually put their data into a GC
bucket knowing that they can recover in
cloud if they ever hit that into
eventualities the benefit that you get
from from a backup product driving that
is obviously overcoming bandwidth
limitations with the integration of
transfer appliance but you get the
benefit of deduplication and compression
as opposed to just copying the data a
flat if you will you have the ability to
perform encryption so you know been
mentioned encryption however you can
still do encryption at that level so if
your backup data is already encrypted
that encryption transfers through and
then the other benefit if you remember
the architecture from the previous slide
you don't need any additional appliances
or gateways to in order actually move
the data to transfer appliance so it
becomes a seamless so we treat from an
architecture standpoint transfer
appliance as though it were an on-prem
GCS bucket and where that comes in handy
is that once the data has been moved to
GCS then you don't have to worry about
having to change formats on that one so
drive and you know adding a few
components to to Benten steps here so I
changed it from you know four steps to
eight steps you perform the ordering you
do the setup etc and then there's
there's a component of what to transfer
so within the convolved infrastructure
you can actually run reports that'll
tell you about the data itself when it's
been touched what files it is so you can
really select what specifically on
transfer here typically what customers
have gone for is they'll select you know
I mean anything beyond 30 days so
they'll consider 0 to 30 day or 0 to 14
days operational recovery things that
they need on Prem to recover immediately
but then beyond that they're maintaining
long-term retention and they want to
transfer that type of data or they going
after a large static file so you can
earn reports against that when you
transfer the data you've got two options
as I mentioned earlier you've got the
ability to do an auxilary copy which
basically means it's sitting in a backup
format somewhere VTL tape library etc
and you want to make a copy of that copy
or it's a full backup that your
baselining the the next step ends up
being disabling any further right so
once the appliance is to transfer
appliance is full we want to completely
disable any writes and data aging why
because it's going to take some time to
for the actual physical appliance to
ship it to stage the data out and in
that meantime if you've got policy setup
that may want to expire data based on
your SL A's or your business
requirements it's not going to be able
to find that appliance so that's
something to to keep in mind the other
aspect is what happens to daily
transfers and one of the things that
we've found is that it's very beneficial
to have the daily transfers especially
if GCS is going to be your ultimate
target to actually have those sent to to
GCS as incrementals and I'll get to a
little bit more on that one so we should
then you ship the appliance you
rehydrate the the data has been
described earlier from there once once
the data actually ends up in a G's in
your GCS bucket within GCP all you have
to do within the common interface is
actually flip a bit to tell it that now
you're writing in a cloud library as
opposed to a pseudo cloud library that
was emulated on the transfer appliance
and why this is important is because
we're going to use your credentials and
your roles within GCS and in order to
get access to that data and to write new
data you enable writes and data aging so
we can treat that as though it were your
data sitting with it within GCS you can
do a test restore record highly
recommended and then you can continue
using GCS for your incremental backups
so first real high real quick high level
best practices from a deduplication
stamp appoint one of the things that we
found with with cloud storage is we can
use very large deduplication sizes
because we can do range reads within
those blocks of data so where we've seen
customers trip trip up especially when
transferring data is on Prem they may be
used to writing a much smaller
deduplication block size however when
they transfer that data is an auxilary
copying to into cloud it's not optimized
so then you have to kind of do a
rehydration and then a deduplication
over so the first time around to
transfer appliance it's beneficial to
just have the right large block size for
deduplication set so it's one of the one
of the best practices the other one is
to definitely disable the backups and
aging what that helps with is not
upsetting your SLA is on-prem that was
the system is aware that that that data
is going to be inaccessible for for a
period of time and one of the benefits
you get is you don't have to with with
the platform have the fools sitting
readable available in order to you for
you to continue doing incrementals so
obviously from a restore perspective you
got to be aware of that and by disabling
it then you'll know what restores are
not available and then sufficient
bandwidth for interim and daily
incrementals and really this is the
sizing question of do I want decides for
for peak or do I want to size for
incremental so you still want to
consider your incrementals and start
writing those incrementals straight to
GCS so what I really mean by that is
rated on on the right side so for super
simplification let's assume you've got
500 terabytes of data you've got a
gigabit bandwidth available to do the
transfer and let's say you've got about
two percent change rate of net new data
coming in one option is you write the
five hundred terabytes as is through the
transfer appliance or if you were to do
it over the network that would take
about 51 days to to to transfer the data
you duplicate it and compress it that
ends up being about a hundred terabytes
which you could write in in ten days
over the network but then what you have
to worry about is in those ten days
there's gonna be change rate generated
which means then you have to recursively
catch up on that and recursively catch
up on the next and the next and the next
and of course we're assuming there's no
growth so the idea here is that the 100
terabytes deduplicated and compressed is
written into the transfer appliance to
transfer appliance to put on the truck
and sent across let's assume it takes
two weeks to get that data to show up in
your GCS bucket so in those 14 days
you've generated another 28 terabytes
worth of data so now you're kind of at
the position that you were earlier which
is how do I transfer that do I do it
over the network do I get another
transfer appliance so you don't want to
do either one
preferably what you want to do is at the
bottom where you're actually sending
your incrementals which which is 2
terabytes considering it's 2 percent to
GCS directly so now we're talking about
mathematically about
five hours to transfer that data so you
think of it as two buckets you'll have
you'll end up with one bucket that has
your foals or your silly your copied
data and you'll have your second bucket
which will have your incremental data
and from a platform perspective there's
no no complication no issue in for the
system to be able to pick up where the
data lives so if you want to be able to
do a restore it knows it to read from
bucket one an incremental bit from from
from your new bucket versus from your
old bucket in order to pull data so the
important aspect here is that that 28
terabytes or three days because
generating that data while the well the
appliance is on the on the truck and
then you can finally catch up so the
better approach really is at the bottom
where you're just sending incrementals
straight to GCS over your network and
what that ends up being is yeah I can I
can sighs my can keep my network at a at
a gigabit I don't have to provision an
immense amount of bandwidth to account
for the 500 terabytes which would be a
one-time transfer and hopefully you
never have to transfer the five hundred
terabytes back so you never really have
to worry about that
thanks deponent all right so just a
quick summary so we have cloud transfer
service for cloud to cloud transfers
just util for on-prem to cloud transfers
if you have enough bandwidth and
obviously if you don't have enough
bandwidth there's transfer points
[Music]